[Music]
in bridezilla news oh [ __ ] necessary for
the article oh I think it's a good intro
it's submitted by I got something before
I was rudely interrupted submitted by
kanae Oh from Indiana oh that doesn't
exist Indiana a bride canceled her
wedding after friends and family refused
to pitch in cash for the lavish event oh
you guys heard of this story oh my god
it went viral no [ __ ] funny okay
cash only to the Asian wedding no what
that's not true are you supposed to
crowdfund a wedding no I mean you can
but like it's not like a traditional
thing to do and then demand it who's
this [ __ ] I need a back story yeah why
but they'll have that you know the
registry yeah some people just say just
donate to the wedding instead instead of
getting a gift cause it's easier that
way
all right to the honeymoon yeah or
something that's fine but this [ __ ] is
demanding it all right so this story was
first surfaced on Reddit and readied the
most credible source on earth tonight
I love read it yes oh these screenshots
I went up and it's so funny so it starts
it's a lot I'm not gonna read it off oh
that is a lot no this is nothing so this
is the beginning right is that the
bridezilla writing on this is the
bridezilla writing that reminds me of
homework and I'll a format and all that
I'll come to this [ __ ] highlighter
marks in that [ __ ] because it's like
private information like names or I
can't write for [ __ ] anymore
all right so it starts off with her
talking about how she said that she has
to cancel this wedding it's only four
days before the wedding and then she
starts going into the background of her
and her fiance and like the fact that
they have a kid together in the day were
highschool sweethearts and then
now this is where I'm gonna start
reading it because you have to hear her
words it's so funny alright so she's
she's talking about all that and then
she says we managed to save up nearly
15k for a wedding since our love was
like a fairy tale we wanted an
extravagant blowout wedding one where
our son could be included we started
touring venues and were torn between two
a local psychic told us to go with the
more expensive option and we thought why
the hell not
we just needed a little push our dream
wedding amounted to 60k all included
with flights to Aruba all we asked was
for a little help from our friends and
family to make it happen I specifically
I mean specifically asked for cash gifts
how could we have our wealth that we
dreamed of without proper funding we
sacrificed so much and only asked each
guest for around 1,500
only only there's so much more we talked
to a few friends we talked to a few
people who even promised us more to make
our dream come true my maid of honor who
shall not be named pledge $5,000 along
with her planning services we tearfully
thinked and excessively my hat my ex's
family offered to contribute 3,000 won
that's a smart leaving me they broke up
okay they're still paying for it
no no this is already like she's talking
business after oh so she's talking about
her fiance but now she's calling him oh
that's so he's really smart yeah dodged
a bullet so then she says really they
have a cake offer to contribute three
thousand dollars so our request for 1500
for all of their guests was not [ __ ]
out of the ordinary like we made it
clear if you couldn't contribute you
weren't invited to our exclusive wedding
it's a once-in-a-lifetime party for her
yeah for her know we sent out RSVPs and
only eight people replied and sent us a
check we were [ __ ] livid that's
pretty good yeah how was this supposed
to happen without a little help from our
friends to make matters worse my ex's
family took back their offer suddenly
more people backed out including the
cuts maid of honor my best friend's his
childhood my second family I was so
shocked and tearful to make matters
worse it was only a month before the
wedding to cancel everything would have
been more than $5,000 desperately we
resent the invites and ask people to
donate what they could
I mean seriously people what is $1,000
what is 1,500 clearly not a lot damn it
would it would be quite manageable and
within budgets I've heard of people
asking for worse we also set up a
GoFundMe that would that only got us
$250 at this point we were exhausted
tired I yelled at my ex I became
unraveled I realized my dream wedding
was becoming a nightmare then it got
worse my ex came into the room and
offered to get a Vegas wedding done I
laughed in his face but he was dead
serious
all the Vegas wedding I laughed in his
face yep some old-fashioned [ __ ] dude
the water show that long ass cigarette
[Laughter]
[Applause]
she said he wanted those cheap he wanted
those cheap raggedy filthy [ __ ] like
Vegas weddings I mean what the [ __ ] was
he out of his mind am i some hoochie
piece of [ __ ] trash a hooker am I
supposed to like the ideas poor married
in the morning gang I was okay she's
good knows my clothes thank you
[Laughter]
am I supposed to like the idea of
getting married in the heart of shady
gamblers alcoholics and get rich fast
dream suddenly my body began to shake as
I entered a panic attack
right here she must be a very
interesting person to be around
she's so entertaining yeah my ex left
the room and didn't apologize for his
horrid suggestion I then called my maid
of honor and cried my eyes out
instead of sympathy I was told I was
asking for way too much and I should
stick to my budget I mean no words can
describe how could someone who offered
me thousands of [ __ ] dollars then
deny me my promised money and then tell
me to shift down my budget she knows my
[ __ ] dream was a blowout wedding I
just wanted to be a Kardashian for a day
and then live live my life like oh my
god I called her a filthy [ __ ] poor
of excuse
Brandon hung up she loved that were
filthy I love it she must be really good
in bed was continuing yeah
then she's blocking it through life if
you make it there charlie spits in your
eyes she [ __ ] about to mention in the
beginning of this whole story she was
saying that she was gonna spend like
time in South America she's running away
as a prisoner oh then she blocked me off
of social media rumors swirled I
received anonymous threats my ex stayed
out late later and later and I have a
feeling he even cheated my bridesmaids
climbed on tomorrow with my bane of
honor and diss me they essentially told
me I was crazy they asked for their
deposit back so I said [ __ ] you I refuse
to give it back until they can pay me
back for their emotional distress my ex
started to talk to my maid of honor and
gossip about me behind my back
I overheard him talking in the basement
and when he called me a stuck-up [ __ ]
anyway I'm exhausted
I am bone tired my heart is not the same
my fingers hurt I've been typing too
much fragmented and I have to get away
from this awful society how hard would
it have been to just [ __ ] donate
friends do i matter - yeah [ __ ] give
me money for my wedding
I won't even sugarcoat it I won't even
pretend that's not what I wanted it was
for a dream I was stabbed cheated on and
worked good bye see you in two months
friendly reminder to you [ __ ] don't
think you own me I am cutting all of you
snakes out off I am living my life alone
now I only let those I believe have good
intention sincerely TIFF imagine you
executed the way she read it or the way
she wrote it like so well she really hot
I don't have a photo so she better don't
yeah she better be like the hottest
thing I've ever seen in my life and even
that is unacceptable
the only thing we know about her is that
her name is Susan because these two
college students there's no hot Susan
you're out of your mind Susan tell us
she's ugly as [ __ ] shouldn't the only
person she should be mad at as a psychic
like she should be like okay you need 60
G's but it's not gonna happen
ya husband's gonna cheat on you no one's
gonna donate 1500 you're gonna want to
go to Aruba good point
like she can see her future right is
that the psychic spot or is it her fault
for walking into a psychic building oh
maybe they say right maybe this psychic
saw that she was a big-ass client and
she was like imma let this [ __ ] go
through that's probably what it was
because she probably told her everything
and she goes oh my god how did you
figure this out because you're a [ __ ]
that [ __ ] you look at a palm oh you're a
[ __ ] that's all this psychic was the
husband I was supposed to be you're just
trying to find a way out so you figured
you'd get sabotager
he'll have a good excuse and she'll
sound even worse right is that there's a
lot of delusional people like this that
are so selfish they think that the whole
world is against them and they have no
[ __ ] clue that they do all that [ __ ]
to themselves and it's funny watching
them crumble hilarious when I see people
[ __ ] their own lives up I feel like the
Kardashians are like we got another one
yeah yes they're calling her comedian
Susan she's Canadian I swear she was
American yeah I totally thought she is
it might make sense if she's like so
loaded that $1,000 to her is like
nothing - yeah like she's not so loaded
she only had 15 grand or what I mean by
that if she grew up loaded so the number
is not something that she's fazed by but
she can't earn herself in the beginning
the part that I skipped over is she was
saying that they worked really hard for
that money then she's an idiot for not
accomplishing her own goal and a wedding
shouldn't be a dream or a goal either in
my personal opinion that's something
that happens in life if that's the
extent of what you thought your human
capability was you're a piece of trash
anyways you should move beyond that like
what the [ __ ] after you get married your
life doesn't end what was your dream
after that
yeah those fault that is it's Walt
Disney's fault easy
he created watch what you say hear me
out you know I'm going with this you
Disney movies get you in your childhood
and then every girl grows up thinking
that it's Prince Charlie it's gonna be
this Prince Charming thing but then when
you meet the man of your dreams and he's
a a little bit on welfare we can't do
that and then we start trying to raise
money I understand her matter all right
justified it's the diamond industry I
think they I think they did the
conspiracies and they said like you know
what we're gonna implant the idea to all
ladies that if a guy doesn't spend a lot
of money then he doesn't love you oh
[ __ ] that dude he's been a [ __ ]
I love you Mary oh [ __ ] yo [ __ ] person
who uploaded all this to social media it
was her cousin
it's another cousin saying like this
came out of nowhere like this is well
she is kind of like high maintenance
work for her baby shower she's asking
for like luxury things but she never has
thought that she would be like this so
she only left this up for about 15
minutes and then she deleted it everyone
thinks that she was drunk when she wrote
it no one is believing her as she's
gonna go to South America
of course not she can't afford it she's
for the ocean you've never let the UN in
New York not the barrack I want to know
people like this so I could laugh a lot
in life but I don't want them to close
cuz I'll be tired you know what I mean
[Music]
yes yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]